hi everyone I am mayank and welcome to
this amazing video on AIML projects by
simple learn in this video we will clear
your doubts regarding the projects you
can add to your resume to clear the
interview or Advance your career in Ai
and machine learning but but before we
begin if you enjoy watching these type
of videos and find them interesting
subscribe to our YouTube channel as we
bring you the best videos daily also hit
the Bell icon to never miss any update
from Simply learn so let's get started
so these projects are not learning
experience they are your passport to an
impressive resume and coveted
opportunity hands on Mastery on these
projects showcases your practical skills
setting you apart in the competitive job
market our inaugural project sets the
stage for the remarkable path ahead the
face recognition system after that we
will see how we predict personality by
implementing personality prediction
system we will cover the speech
recognition system and after that we
will cover projects like fake news
detection and headspace detection system
we will see how we can classify image
using CNN after that we will see the
movie recommendation system and the
world of algorithms that understand your
preferences and curate movie suggestion
tailor made for you in the end we will
see a text to speech conversation system
for an accelerating ride through the
ramps of artificial intelligence data
science and Innovation the job
opportunities in machine learning are as
very stranging and abundant as a
technology application the average
annual salary income for machine
learning engineers in U.S is 140 000 in
the US and in India its annual salary is
20 lakh per annum on that node if you
are an expiring AIML engineer there is
no better time to train yourself in the
exciting field of machine learning if
you are looking for a course that covers
everything from fundamentals to Advanced
Techniques like machine learning
algorithm development and unsupervised
learning look no further than our
Caltech in partnership with IBM this AI
ml bootcampment collaboration with
Caltech will help you advance your
career as an AIML specialist the AIML
bootcamp includes live classes delivered
by industry experts Hands-On lab
Industries 11 projects and master
classes by Caltech Professor key
features of this amazing machine
learning course include and up to 22 cus
from caltex crtma online convocation by
Caltech ctma program director simply
runs Career Services helps you get
noticed by top hiring companies earn a
bootcamp certificate from caltex ctma 25
plus Hands-On projects across industry
verticals to integrated lab so why wait
join now seats are filling fast and the
find the course link from the
description box below so without any
further Ado over to our training expert
so in today's session we will see what
opencv is moving forward we will see
what is space detection and at the end
we will go through the hands of live
demo of how we can create phase
detection using opencv python we will
perform different function and use
different python libraries to create
phase detection
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what opencv is and
proceed further for the same
what is opencv
a collection of python bindings called
opencv
python was created to address issue with
the computer vision
python is general purpose programming
language created by Judo Von Rasam that
quickly gained popularity largely due to
its ease of use and readable code the
programmer can express Concept in less
code without sacrificing readability
numpy a highly efficient library for
numerical operation with a Matlab like
syntax is used by opencv python numpy
arrays are translated into and out of
all opencv array forms additionally this
make it simpler to interact with other
numpy using libraries like sci-fi and
matplotlib after understanding what is
opencv let's move forward and see what
phase detection is so what is Phase
detection
phase detection also known as facial
detection is a computer technology that
uses artificial intelligence to find and
recognize human faces in digital
photographs
Fair Direction technology can be enabled
real-time surveillance and tracking of
people in various Industries such as
security Biometrics law enforcement
entertainment and personal safety
from basic computer vision method to
developments in machine learning to
increasingly use complex artificial
neural network and related Technologies
phase detection has advanced leading or
to ongoing performance increases
it now serves as the foundation from
some crucial applications such as face
tracking phase analysis face recognition
the application ability to perform
sequential tasks subsequently impacts
the phase Direction
so dear Leonard if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skills so
give a chance to Simply land
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box below
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or give your answer
in the chat section so I can see if the
answer is given by you are right or
wrong
so the question is which of the
following function is a built-in
function in Python
factorial
print
seed
sqrt
so I am starting the timer of one minute
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section please do
let me know your answers
so I'm starting the timer of one minute
each of the following function is a
built-in function in Python factorial
print seed sqrt let us know your answer
in the comment section below
I kindly ask that everyone take part in
this session
which of the following function is a
built-in function in Python
30 seconds more factorial print seed
sqrt
please let me know your answer in the
comment section below
20 seconds remaining
each of the volume function is a
built-in function in Python
10 seconds more
please let us know your answer in the
comment section below
so after the allotted time has passed
Those Who provided the current response
will receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
so now let's move to our programming
part to create phase detection using
opencv python
so first we will open command prompt to
write a command to open jupyter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you have to select new
python file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating a phase
detection system
so first let me rename this
paste
Direction
first we will import import
CV2
press enter then import another Library
import numpy
as NP
and the third one is Major One Import
face
recognition
as
fr
then press enter
so CV means capturing video
the CV2 function is opencv can read
video video capture by using pass 0
function parameter we can access our
webcam we may pass as rtsp URL in the
function parameter to capture the CCTV
footage
which is quite helpful for video
analysis
and another one is numpy numpy is a
python Library used for working with
arrays it also has function for working
in the domain of lineal algebra and
matrices
it is in open source project you can use
it freely numpy stands for numerical
python
and the third one is Phase recognition
phase recognition and manipulation using
python or the command line the easiest
facial recognition library in the world
built using Cutting Edge face
recognition technology from dlib
developed using deep learning
so moving forwards let's import our
video capture device so for that we have
to write Here video
underscore capture this is our variable
name
equals to
CV2 Dot
video
capture
and we have to pass here zero
then press enter
okay here we
should be capital
so the video capture function from
opencv is used to interact with the
cameras what we can do is video can be
shown and saved display the image that
the camera captured
so moving forward let me import my image
for the further detection process okay
so
image equals to
FR dot load
underscore image
underscore file
then
image name or image path boy
dot jpg
press enter
using load image file we can import
image file to our detection system so
moving forward let's set encoding for
the image okay so I will write here
image underscore phase underscore
encoding
equals to
FR Dot
face
recordings
and image
than zero
press enter
yeah
so face encoding basically uses 128
computer generated measures to represent
the phase similar encoding would be
present in two images of the same person
while being completely different in two
images of two distinct people
so moving forward let's do let me write
first
I will write here known
encodings
equals to
image
face
coding
okay
then press enter
then known
phase
names
equals to
then here I have to put my name so I
will write
Bank
okay then press enter
so what I did is I assigned known page
encodings to my image face encoding so
what will happen if image matches to my
face then it will print my name and for
the rest we will add name unknown okay
so let me add the function now for phase
detection system
so let me write the full code for it
first then I will explain you line wise
okay
so just stay tuned with me
I will write here
so I will add while
okay true
okay so r e t comma frame I will explain
you line wise line don't worry equals to
then video
capture
dot read
and RGB
underscore frame
was to
frame
then colon
comma then again colon comma then two
colon
then minus 1.
okay
yeah
so here I will write FC underscore
locations
equals to FR dot face
underscore locations
RGB
underscore frame
write here FC FC is for basically phase
encodings
was to fr
dot phase
underscore encodings
and RGB
underscore frame
comma FC underscore
locations
okay
so for
top
comma right comma
bottom
on my left
okay then I have to write a face
the score encoding
comma face underscore encoding this is
that was encodings this is encoding
okay so before that I will write here
Okay so
I have to write here encoding
in zip
okay then here I have to write
FC underscore
locations locations
okay
then
comma then face encodings
colon
then press enter
so here I have to write matches
yeah
matches equals to FR dot compare
and faces
then known
the score phase
score encodings
comma phase underscore encoding
okay
so
it
so what if
the image will not match so I have to
give the name equals to
unknown
then we will write phase distances
plus two
FR dot phase
underscore distances
the score phase
underscore encodings
comma
paste
score and coding
then I will write match underscore index
equals to NP Dot
AR
G min
okay then I will write here FC
underscore distances
yeah
then moving forward
I have lied if
matches
then match underscore
index
okay then colon
the name
equals to
known underscore phase
underscore names
then
match underscore index
and I have to write here CV2
Dot rectangle
and frame
comma
comma top
comma right
to give another bracket here
comma
bottom
that comma
0 comma zero comma 255
again comma then 2 for the Border
so then CV2 dot rectangle
yeah
oh Mom then again
left comma
bottom
then minus
35.
okay
so then I will write
comma bottom
comma
then again 0 comma 0 comma 255
then CV2 dot f i l l e d field
okay F should be capital
yeah
so then we will set font equals to
CV2
Dot
font
okay
the score
underscore
simplex
okay
so then I have to write here
CV2
dot put
text
aim
comma name
comma
left
six
comma bottom
minus six
okay then comma point
comma
1.0 then
again one comma then we have to set
location like 255
comma 255
then comma
1.
okay
and here I have to write CV2
dot image show I am show
then like
simply learn
this detection
comma frame
and if
CV2 Dot
weight key
is one
and
like 0 x
f
capital f f equals to equals to
ORD then
quit
and here I will write break
I will write video
underscore capture
dot release
TV2
dot destroy
all
windows
okay
yeah
so let me explain you
so in general rad is a Boolean value
that indicates whether or not there was
a even a return each frame that is
returned is at the same frame if there
is no frame you will receive none rather
than an error
in opencv reading and writing videos and
reading and writing images are quite
similar a video is nothing more than a
collection of pictures often known as
frames
so to draw a rectangle around the face
that was discovered we utilize the
opencv rectangle
the rectangle function we can draw the
rectangle by using the points or Corner
position that the phase location
and
is encoding this a face encoding this
one
so a face encoding basically uses 128
computer generated measures to represent
the phase similar encoding what we
present in two images of the same person
while being completely different in two
images of two distinct people
so this there is a use compare phase
so compare phase is used to compare my
face to uploaded image one okay if it
matches it will print my name otherwise
we have given a known here
so the numpy argr
this one
but it went this numpy ARG min
so the number ARG main method delivers
the indexes of the arrays minimum
element along each axis return an array
of array indices with the same shape of
the array
so this font where is yeah
font herces simplex
is normal size of sans serif font okay
so put text put text is used to put the
text on the frame like my name or
unknown
so in order to display an image in a
window we use the IM show this one
this I am sure function
okay so the window address itself to the
size of image parameters window name a
string that identifies the window in
which the displayed image will appear
okay
so until a key is pressed wait key zero
this one okay so until a key is pressed
weight key zero will will keep the
window open it is suitable for image
display and wait key one
I write here wait key one so wait key
one will show a frame for one Ms before
closing the display on its own
so after the script has ended users can
close or remove all the windows use the
python
like using destroy all function function
okay you would use the function if you
wanted to close a window while it was
open in numerous windows at once
so let's see our phase detection system
is working or not so let me close this
person on your screen first okay
so let me close this first
let me run this
now so here you can see this pop-up and
I will open so here you can see my name
is correctly printing
so
like I have uploaded my image it's
directing correctly okay
so like what if I show uh one more image
so here you can see this is my card
so it is
detecting properly
yeah
so what if I will show like another guy
image so
from my mobile
so here you can see
it is spring unknown in
message photo
yeah
so what if if I will write here like uh
one of the
other image this random dot jpg then it
should print unknown for me also okay
then I will run it again
okay it's working
that's what has come
so here you can see it is now printing
unknown because like I have uploaded
that another random image here so it is
importing
okay so it is printing unknown here
so here you can see like it's spreading
unknown for me also
so in today's session we will go through
Myers-Briggs Personality prediction
after that a hands-off lab demo of how
to predict the person's personality
using Python and machine learning
we will perform different function and
different python libraries
so before we move on to the programming
part let's first discuss what is
Myers-Briggs Personality prediction and
proceed further for the shape
personality prediction
to better understand personality
characteristics in the broader
population the mbti examination was
created although there is no such thing
as Better or Worse personality prevents
examination can Aid individuals in
understanding their strength weakness
and potential difference from the others
so there are some types of mbti
indicators
there is no best or better personality
type than another
it is not a device made to search for
abnormalities and dysfunction
it is sole purpose is to assist you in
discovering mode about yourself
so there are four separate scales make
up the actual questionnaire first is
extrovert and introversion
second is sensing and intuition
third is thinking and feeling
forth is judging and perceiving
So based in these four there are some
types so there are 16 types
istj istp isfj isfp isfj like this ENFP
e and FJ entp and entj
so what is meaning of isdj
I means introversion s means sensing t
means thinking and J means judging like
this
so dear Learners if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skills so
give yourself a chance to Simply learn a
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box below
so now let's move to our programming
part
so first we will open command prompt
first we will open command prompt so
here I will add Jupiter
enter
so this is landing page of Jupiter
notebook so here I will go new
python file
so this is how the python kernels look
like
so here I will change name
be my aspect personality prediction
okay
so at first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
analyzing the data
so here I will write
lab
report Rd
or numpy as NP
import
pandas as PD
support matplotlib
Pi plot
as PLT
T-Bone
SNS
then code
plotly
dot offline
at
okay
then here import
antly
dot graph
and this
vgs object as go
I'll import
shortly
dot tools
as TLS
from
bs4
import
ant
and here I will write from sqlarn dot
model
underspose selection
port
s underscore validate
okay
then again let me copy from here
till import
ant
then here I will import straight
ified
so
yes so here I will import sqlarn
dot lenient
or model
port
logistic regression
so from this
we'll write here sqlarn
okay
done
dot model underscore selection
port
to learn
Dot
support
the
SE
okay so here I will write mode from
learn dot become position
code
truncated
yeah
so here I will write from
SK learn
Dot
here
underscore
section
text
import
okay
then from sqlarn
dot pipeline
Port pipeline
from SQL on
dot is
multinomial
binomial and B
and
p y Dot
in it
underscore
Financial
connected
is equals to
buy the python Library used for working
with array it also has a function for
working with domain of lineal algebra
and matrices it is open source project
and you can use it freely numpy stand
for numerical python so panda is the
software Library written for the pandas
programming language
for data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data section and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and Time series
open source python Library based on
matplotlib is called C bone it is
utilized for data exploration and data
visualization with data frames and the
pandas Library c bond function with
these
matplotlib for Python and its numerical
extension numpy Metro clip is a cross
platform data visualization and
graphical charting program
as a result it presents a strong open
source substitute for Matlab
the apis format plotlib allows
programmers to incorporate graphs into
GI application
Beautiful soap python software called
Beautiful soup is called Parts HTML and
XML text
for process Pages it generates a pass
tree that can be used to extract HTML
data for web scripting
pipeline the pipeline goal is to put
together several phases that can be
cross-validated while using different
parameters
so moving forward let's import some
different data that you can download
these data set from the description box
below so here I will write train
PD Dot
eat underscore CSV
and then here
PTI
one
Dot
and second one is
equals to
PD Dot
read
underscore
users
let's see
okay
then there is one more
equals to
PD Dot
p
SV
that
forum
suggest
so here I will write mbti
equals to
I
the key value
so I'm writing a keyword
introversion
come on
then game
explosion
it
contributions
[Music]
capital
one one
e
then t means thinking
f means
healing
J means
judging
loading
so it's still loading for data set
three different data set mbti1 CSP users
and Forum messages you can download
these data set from the description box
below
or you can find this link
for the Drive Link
so these are like large data sets so it
will take time sometime
importing is data says done so
let's use shape function to see how many
rows columns are present in train data
set so here I will write train
dot shape
as you can see 8665 8675 rows and two
columns
okay so let's move forward
so wait to take a class
I repeat
so we take a look to classes so it look
like very unbalanced data set so here I
will write CNT
dot that is equals to
train
type
value counts
so here I will plot dot figure
guys
let's do
12 comma four
so
sns.bar plot
PMT
thank you
that is
dot values
to 0.8
of plot dot y label
and says
ties
table
types
different types than font size
LT dot show
okay
so here you can as you can see different
types of Personality infj infj INTP intj
so what
okay
so these are number of occurrence and
the types
so moving forward let's group user ID
and messages so I will write here
first
write a visual
yeah so here I will write PS
message
dot fill any
yes Dot
underscore Joy
equals to PS dot Group by
post
right
message
Dot
get here I will write
all
right
alone
at
the loading
moving forward let's check accuracy with
different classifiers and models
so first we will check with extra tree
classifier
okay
so for that
right here like e t g extra tree
classifier equals to
decrease
classifier
then underscore
estimators
equals to 20
comma Max
plus 2 4
.
equals to
minus
so here I will write TF IDF
equals to
let me copy it from here
and gram
underscore range
pursue
comma one
yeah
upwards
SVD
it was
it
components
does
two
pipeline
PF
I
write DFI
right here
that
thank you
here I will write K Folds
here
I am doing because of spelling mistakes
and uh it's
it's two five
comma Shuffle
and here I will write NP Dot
okay sorry
NP dot random
dot read
ing
issue
Tracy
vlog
in
Indiana
type
the red scoring
notes equals to minus one
it is still loading
okay
looking
now we will print
so here I will write print
TV
then 0.4
f
and I will write
Plus
minus
colon
0.4 f
Dot
B Dot
mean
result
position
results
copy
at all and the chip
accordingly
so now F1 is score for F1 score we will
write here F1
same
okay
then here here right NP dot mean
editor
security here you will write test F1
underscore
micro
okay then same here
test F1
again
for the negative laws
right
love
good
here I will write negative
in this log underscore loss
if
underscore log
underscore
done it
so
wait let me make it
so here you can see the accuracy and
it's it is not that good with xrt
classifier as the data set is very
unbalanced F1 score is a better metric
than accuracy
so we will check with some alternative
models so let's try if we can find a
more accuracy with model another model
although we haven't got a lot of data
so here I will write TF
clean
next
okay
so here I will write text
question
beautiful
ml
three dot sub
then
repeat
r
Oma
okay then text was to re Dot so
then
http
says
button
text
here I will add train
posts
don't
reply
put it okay done so let's check accuracy
with first name base okay
oh I'm done with the code because the
code are mostly same so I just copied it
from
my documents
okay so let me enter
so here you can see uh the accuracy is
far better than
this x30 classifier
okay
so we will check from one mode we will
let's check for logistic regression
so let me write the code first then I
will get back to you
I'm done with the code let's see the
accuracy of logistic regression
so let me press enter
loading you can see
yeah
so accuracy is far good than the both
so is this model overfitting could we
have a better model with more data let's
see the learning curve okay so here I
will write train
underscore sizes
comma train
underscore scores
command
pursue
running underscore girl
done
post
okay
type
apples
jobs
pudding
equals to
here I will write F1 underscore
pane
sizes
equals to NP
Dot
base
1 comma one Prince
num
state
two one
and press enter
okay it is K Falls
this is dispatcher
so for the learning curve it is a long
code
so let me write it for you again it's
still loading
I don't know why
so I'm done with the code so let me run
it
now let's see the Curve
so for that that is that import
or we don't
have that plot learning
I think of
chain
posts
comma trained
type
plane
under sizes
again underscore scores
command
test
underscore scores
comma y
0.0
figure size should be
okay
elt dot show
here as you can see
trainees go across validation Score
Learning graph
so it's look like that with more data
the more model gets better and better so
that is not overfitting
so what we will do
moving forward let's see kaggle user
personality let's apply our model to
whole kaggle user commands let's see
what is the most common casual user
personality
so for that I will write here BS
underscore join
then
comments
equals to
this underscore join
message
Dot
apply
text
foreign
model
underscore learning dot fit
train
posts
type
all equals to model
it
join
it's loading here
so moving forward what what we will do
let's create a bar graph to see kaggle
user personality okay
loading
it will show the warning something like
let me write the code for the paragraph
okay it's a long code so I will write
first then I will get back to you
so I wrote the code so let me run it and
see the personality
so here you can see esfp is the most
used personality
so let's see the count personality count
percentage count for that I will write
here
let's go
DF
percent
to addiction underscore TF
count
and underscore DF
then again count
there I will add prediction underscore
Tia
description
personality
reply
yeah
X
joint
PTI
right button
test
okay
here you can see the percentage count
for every personality
okay with description extroversion
sensing feeling perceiving ESF
so
finally at the end we will see the
personality distribution using pie chart
okay so here I will write labels equals
to prediction
underscore TF
I will write description
yeah
sizes
equals to prediction underscore DF
extent
is equal to go
Dot
I
equals
to labels
comma
values
what's two sizes
layout should be
layout equals to go
dot layout
return
equals to
Kegel user
internalities
data
equals to
Trace
that
oh
Dot
also data
divide Dot
I plot
okay
let me turn it
let me run it
so here you can see the pie chart
so like most fifty percent is e s f p
okay then 23 is introversion institution
then
so on okay so everything is written here
and every color
so apparently the most common calculator
user personality is esfp this is 50.6
percent okay
so extroversion sensing feeling
perceiving but we are getting this
conclusion based on users command it is
reasonable to think that user who
participate more writing comments are
more extrovert our sample data don't
come from the kaggle users population it
is only based on the comments
it comes from the kaggle users command
so our conclusion can't be applied to
all kaggle users
so like more accuracy models could be
obtained in more data
on that node if you are an expiring AIML
engineer there is no better time to
train yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you are looking for
a course that covers everything from
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our Caltech in partnership
with IBM this AI ml bootcampment
collaboration with Caltech will help you
advance your career as an AIML
specialist the AIML bootcamp includes
live classes delivered by industry
experts Hands-On lab Industries 11
projects and master classes by Caltech
Professor key features of this amazing
machine learning course include and up
to 22 cus from Cadillac citme online
convocation by Caltech ctme program
director simply runs Career Services
helps you get noticed by top hiring
companies earn a bootcamp certificate
from caltex ctma 25 plus Hands-On
projects across industry verticals to
integrated lab so why wait join now
seats are filling fast and the find the
course link from the description box
below so in today's session we will go
through what is a speech recognition
system moving forward we will see how
speech recognition system works after
that we will create a speech recognition
system using python
we will perform different function and
create speech recognition system using
different python libraries before we
move on to the programming part let's
discuss what is a species recognition
system first and proceed further for the
same
what is a specific cognition system
a program capacity to convert spoken
language into written language is known
as a speech recognition system also
known as automatic CS recognition
computer voice recognition or speech to
text despite being sometimes confused
with voice recognition speech
recognition focus on converting speech
form a verbal to a text format whereas
voice recognition only aims to
distinguish the voice of a certain
person
voice and speech recognition are two
distance Technologies and they shouldn't
be confused
to recognize word in spoken language
speech recognition is used voice
recognition uses biometrical
Technologies to recognize a specific
person by their voice
so after knowing what is speech
recognition system let's move forward
and see how does speech recognition
system work
peace recognition in Python works with
algorithm that perform linguistic and
acoustic modeling acoustic modeling is
used to recognize phonetics in our space
to get the more significant part of
speech as words and sentences speech
recognition start by taking the sound
energy produced by the person speaking
and converting it into the electrical
energy
with the help of microphone it then
converts the electrical energy from
analog to digital and finally to the
text
it breaks the audio data down into
sounds and it analyzes the sound using
algorithm to find the most probable word
that fits that audio
all of this is done using natural
language processing NLP and neural
networks
hidden Markov models can be used to find
temporal patterns in speech and improve
accuracy so here is one question for you
guys I will give you one minute for this
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answers given by your right or
wrong
I am repeating again so here is one
question for you guys I will give you
exactly one minute for this you can
comment or you can give answer in the
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong
so the question is which of the
following is the correct extension for
the python file
I am repeating again which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file
option a DOT python option b dot PL
option C Dot py and option D dot p
so let us know your answer in the
comment section below
so I'm starting a timer of one minute
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section do let me
know your answers please I kindly ask
that everyone take part in this to make
this live session exciting
so I am starting the timer
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong so the question is which of the
following is the correct extension of
the Python file
37 seconds remaining
option a DOT python option b dot PL
option C dot py option D dot p
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
I can't ask that everyone take part in
this to make the live session exciting
you have 15 seconds remaining
10 seconds more
which of the following is the correct
extension of the Python file
three two one after that allotted time
has passed Those Who provided the
correct or response will receive as
response and those Who provided the
incurrent response will receive one
okay so now let's move to our
programming part to create a speech
recognition system using python so first
we will open a command prompt to write a
command to open jupyter notebook so here
we will write Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you can select new
python file
so this is how the Jupiter notebook UI
looks like so at first we will import
some major libraries of python which
will help us in creating speech
recognition system
so here we will write
first let me remain rename this
so first I will import import
teach
underscore
recognition
and second import
S three
press enter
so the incredibly attention I repeat the
incredibly extensible speech recognition
Library serves as a wrapper for a number
of well-known speech apis
the speech recognition Library includes
default API key for one of these the
Google web speech API hard-coded that
implies that you can start moving
without needing to register for a
service
and python project would benefit greatly
from using the speech recognition
package due to its versatility and
usability
and then pydts X3 a python text to
speech conversion library is called pyts
X3
it is compatible with python 2 and
Python 3 and work offline unlike
competing libraries to obtain a
reference to a pyts X3 engine instance
an application calls the pyts X3 init
it is very user friendly program that
turns tab text to into speech
so moving forward let's write code for
actual speech recognition system
so here I will write
Sr equals to speech
underscore
recognition
Dot
recognizer
R must be Capital here
here I will write with
speech
underscore
recognition
dot microphone
apps
source
2.
then colon
yeah
here
I will write print
right here okay silence
is
then I will write here Sr dot adjust
underscore for underscore
ambient
underscore noise
then source 2 comma duration
equals to 2.
okay
then enter
then I will print something like
geek
now
please
something like that
then I will write here audio
to
equals to Sr
Dot listen
source
2.
and here I will write for text equals to
Sr
Dot
recognize
yeah
underscore
Google
audio
2.
then here I have to print in small
letters
in lower case so I will write here text
equals to text
dot lower
this
then here I will write print
it you say
Plus
text
everything look great
so a recognizer is a machine ability to
listen to spoken words and identify them
you can then use a speech recognition in
Python to convert the spoken words into
text make a query or a giveaway reply
you can even program some devices to
respond to these spoken words
like every time the recognized speech
from mic function is invoked the
recognizer is calibrated for changing
noise condition using the edges for
ambient noise this one for ambient noise
the backlog parameter of the listen
function allow a quiz size to be
specified it will listen to what we are
speaking or saying
this recognize Google
a function on the recognizer class
which you have now developed will be
used to query the Google web speech API
and convert spoken words into text
recognize Google needs the argument
audio data in order to function properly
otherwise it will fail
python built-in function lower is mostly
used to handle strings
the lower method converts each Capital
character in The provided string to
lowercase before returning the lower
caste string it accept no arguments it
returned to the original text if the
supplied string has no capital letters
now let's check whether it's working or
not so I will run it yeah
Renault
hello how are you doing
yeah you can see hello how are you doing
printed
so let me try another one
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
so here you can see subscribe to Simply
on YouTube channel and press that Bell
icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn is printed
so a speech to text is working fine
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any queries
regarding any code or you have any
questions just put us in comments our
team will shortly provide you with the
correct solution
now moving forward what if you want that
system will write what we are saying and
speak that too
this will be printed and now moving
forward what if you want the system will
write what we are saying and speak that
too
so for that we will write a small line
of code
so first we will do
we will create one here
like we will insert cell below we will
write a function here so d f
speak now
command
colon then voice equals to
p y t t s x 3
dot init
okay
then voice dot say
command
and voice
dot run
and
wait
yeah
so what we will do here
we will write like speak
now
then
so this voice is nothing just a variable
to text to speech and init pytx3 engine
has started obtains a pointer to an
instance of an engine that will utilize
the specified driver
if another engine stand is already using
the given driver the other engine stance
is written if not a new engine is built
a speed now is a function in which using
get function I am getting the values of
the text this one I will get
now let's run this sort of code and
let's see if it is working or not so I
will run
hello how are you all
Peak now is not different okay
speak now okay and is small
okay my bad ranges again
hello how are you all
I hope you can hear properly so let me
run this again for another demo example
subscribe to Simply learn YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
subscribe to simple and YouTube channel
and press the Bell icon to never miss
any updates from simplerlearn yeah so I
hope you guys understand Taylor if you
have any question or any queries
regarding any code
or you have any question related to
python just put as in comments our team
will shortly provide you with the
correct solution
okay okay moving forward so at last
let's create a speech recognition system
from which we can open our websites and
all like YouTube like Facebook like
simply learn anything so we will open
open new file for this I will create the
separate one
here I will write speech
to web
websites
okay
speech
to web
so here I will import import speech
underscore
recognition
and
import
pyts X3
then one major Library import
web browser
okay then I will run it yeah
I hope you already know these two first
two libraries so this is third library
is used for
web browser is the file source code the
web browser modules offers a high level
user interface that enables user to view
web-based content
in most cases executing the open
function from the this module will
result in the desired outcome
so moving forward let me write code for
it
so I will write code first then I will
explain you line wise
so I will write
if
underscore underscore
name
then again to underscore equals to
equals to
underscore main then again underscore
then colon
yeah then you have to give a path like
for your browser you can use Edge you
can use Google Chrome anything Firefox
anything
so here I will give path path equals to
then
C drive I have my path
already
program
files
and
X 86.
Microsoft
and Edge
then
okay then
application
then msh
dot e x e
you have to write at the end this
percentage s
don't forget to write this
okay so path is set so let me create Sr
equals to
speech
recognition
Dot
recognizer
same as previous one
and I will write with
speech underscore
recognition
Dot microphone
as source
and Sr dot adjust
or
ambient
noise
then source
yeah everything seems good
let me write print
but we have wrote there like speak
now please so here I will write
please
a something
to open
okay
I'll write audio
equals to
Sr Dot listen
that source
and I will print
like what you said
so it will here hearing
and I will here I try and accept
then try
so here I will write destination
equals to Sr
dot recognize
underscore Google
then audio
print
you asked
to open
right here Plus
destination
okay
so then web
browser
a browser dot get
that path
then open
that destination
destination
okay
so here I will write that accept
caption
as
you can write e
then print
if there will be error
better
stia
e
okay
so I recognize the machine ability to
listen to spoken words and identify them
you can use speech recognition in Python
to convert the spoken word into text you
can even program some devices to respond
to these spoken words every time they
recognize the speech from mic function
is invoked the recognizer is calibrated
for changing noise condition using the
adjust ambient noise method
a socket is all ready to receive
connection after calling the listen
function prior to performing the accept
method on the server socket the listen
method should be called the backlog
parameter of the listen function allow a
queue size to be specified it will
listen to what we are speaking or saying
the recognized Google function on the
recognizer class which you have now
developed will be used to query the
Google web speech API and will convert
spoken words into text
recognize Google needs the argument
audio data in order to function properly
otherwise it will fail
okay
so okay so let's try this it's working
or not
let me run this
okay invalid syntax perhaps you forgot a
comma
okay let me see
that print
error
Inc it should be yeah
okay let me check this
thank you
let me run this again
valid syntax perhaps you forgot a comma
okay
try to run this again
two
okay let me remove this
I guess it will work fine
still
didn't put okay okay no issues
so here I will write
again
accept
ion
e
and
errors
TR okay I forgot to write plus okay okay
e
yeah now it will work fine
www.youtube.com
so here you can see YouTube is open
yeah
so we will try this one more time
www.facebook.com
so here you can see Facebook is open
one more last time
www.simplyland.com
you can check our amazing courses on
different different Technologies here on
simply learn website simplylean.com
so in today's session we will discuss
what fake news is and at the end we will
do a hands of lab demo of how to detect
fake news using machine learning
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss first what fake news
is and proceed further for the same
what is fake news
polls are misleading information that is
reported as news is called fake news a
common goal or fake news is to harm
someone or something reputation or to
profit through advertising
the term fake news was first used in
1890s a time when dramatic newspaper
reports were common
even though incorrect information has
always been disamented throughout
history
however the phrase has no clear
definition and is often used to refer to
all misleading information high profile
individuals have also used it to refer
to any news that is not favorable to
them
so dear Learners if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skill so
give yourself a chance to Simply learn
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with a
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course details from the
description box below now let's move to
our programming part
so first we will open a command prompt
to write a command to open Jupiter
notebook so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
Center
and here I have to set new python kernel
file
okay so this is how the kernel look
likes
so first we will import some major
libraries of python so here I will write
import
ance as PD
and import
numpy
as NP
then
import
c bond
that's SNS
and import
sklearn
dot model selection
port
train underscore
test underscore split
before that I will import
matplotlib
dot Pi plot
as PLT
okay then
I will write here from SK learn
Dot
Matrix
import
accuracy
or
than from
SK learn
dot matrix
import
classification
to report
and port
Ari then import
string
okay
then press enter
so it is saying
okay
here I have to write from
everything seems good
loading let's see
okay till then number is a python
Library used for working with arrays
which also has function for working with
domain of lineal algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely
number stand for numerical python
pandas so panda is a software Library
written for Python programming language
for data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data structure and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and Time series
then Seaborn
an open source python Library based on
matplotlib is called C bone it is
utilized for data exploration and data
visualization
with data frames and the pandas Library
c-bond functions with ease
than matplotlib for Python and its
numerical extension numpy
matplotlib is a cross platform for the
data visualization and graphical
charting package
as a result it presents a strong open
source suitable for Matlab
the apis format plot live allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
GUI applications then this train test
split we may build our training data and
the test data with the aid of SQL and
train test split function
this is so because the original data set
often serves as both the training data
and the test data starting with a single
data set we divide it into two data sets
to obtain the information needed to
create a model like hone and test
accuracy score the accuracy score is
used to gauge the model's Effectiveness
by calculating the ratio of total true
positive to Total to negative across all
the model prediction
this re regular expression
the function in the model allow you to
determine whether a given text fits a
given regular occupation or not
which is known as re
okay then string a collection of letters
words or other characters is called a
string it is one of the basic data
structure that serves as the foundation
of manipulating data
the Str class is a built-in string class
in Python because python strings are
immutable they cannot be modified after
they have been formed
okay so now let's import the data set we
will be going to import two data set one
for the fake news and one for the True
News or you can say not fake news okay
so I will write here
EF underscore
pick
pursue
PD Dot
read underscore CSV
or what can I say TF fake okay
it underscore fake
okay
then
pick
dot CSV
you can download this data set from the
description box below
then data Dot
true
PD dot read
underscore CSV
sorry CSG
then
big news sorry true
true dot CSV
okay then press enter
so these are the two data set
you can download these data sets from
the description box below so let's see
the board data set okay
then I will write here data underscore
fake
dot head
so this is the fake data okay then
data underscore true
Dot
and this is the two data
okay this is not fake so if you want to
see your top five rows of the particular
data set you can use head
and if you want to see the last five
rows of the data set you can use tail
instead of head
okay
so let me give some space for the better
visual
so now we will insert column class as a
Target feature okay then I will write
here data
let's go fake
Plus
equals to zero
then
Theta underscore true
and
Plus
one
okay
then
I will write here data underscore fake
dot shape
and
data underscore true
dot ship
okay then press enter
so the shape method return the shape of
an array the shape is a tuple of
integers these number represent the
length of the corresponding array
dimension in other words a tuple
containing the quantities of entries on
each axis is an array shape dimension
so what's the meaning of shape
in the fake world
in this data set we have two three four
eight one rows and five columns
and in this data set true
we have two one four one seven rows and
five column okay so these are the rows
column rows column for the particular
data set
so now let's move
and let's remove the last 10 rows for
the manual testing okay
then I will write here data underscore
speak
let's go manual
testing
was to
data underscore fake
dot tail
was it last 10 rows I have to write here
10.
okay so for I
in range
two three four
eight one
sorry zero
comma 2 3
4 7 0
comma minus 1.
okay
and
TF underscore not DF data
underscore fake
dot drop
one
instead of one I can write here I
comma
this equals to zero
place
question true
then
data
not here
data underscore
same I will write for I will copy from
here
and I will paste it here and I will make
the particular changes
so here I can write true
that I can write true
okay
then I have to change a number
two one
right
2 1 4 0 6
-1
same
so press enter
X is equals to zero
alert since X maybe you mean double zero
or of this
okay we will put here double course
well I am putting this
egg dot drop i x is equal to zero okay
in place okay
and also write equals to an equation
yeah
so
okay axis is not defined
now it's working so
let me see
now
did the underscore
fake dot shape
okay
and data dot true
and
data underscore true
dot shape
as you can see
10 rows are deleted from each data set
so I will write here data underscore
fake underscore manual
testing
Plus
equals to zero
and data underscore
true
underscore
manual underscore testing
class equals to
1.
okay
just ignore this funding
and
let's see
data underscore
fake underscore
manual
testing dot hat
as you can see we have this
and then data dot sorry underscore true
underscore manual
testing
dot at
10.
this is this is the uh true data set
so here I will merge data
underscore merge
PD Dot
concat
concat is used for the concatenation
data underscore fake
data underscore
comma
axis
equals to zero
then data underscore merge
dot head
your top 10 rows
yeah
as you can see the data is merged
here
first it will come for the fake news and
then with that for the True News
and let's merge true and fake data
frames
okay
we did this and
let's merge the column then data dot
merge
Dot
columns or let's see the columns
it is not defined what are the data
underscore much
these are the column same title tag
subject date class okay
now
let's remove those columns which are not
required for the further process so here
I will write data underscore
or request to
data underscore merge
crop
title I don't need
that
subject
we don't need
then
so one
so let's check some null values
it's giving here
because of this
that's good then data
dot is null
dot sum
Center
so no null values
okay then
let's do the random shuffling of the
data frames okay
for that we have to write here data
equals to
data dot sample
one
then
data
okay
dot hat
okay now you can see here the random
shuffling is done
and one for the
true data reset and zero for the fake
news one okay
then
let me write here data Dot
reset
underscore index
place
because you
true
a dot dot drop
comma X is
equals to 1
then comma in place
true true
okay
then let me see columns now data Dot
columns
so here we have two columns only rest we
have deleted
okay
so
see data Dot at
yeah
everything seems good
let's proceed further and let's create a
function to process the text okay
for that I will write here
but
okay
you can use any name
text
and text equal to
text Dot lower
okay
and text
for the substring
remove these things
from the
datas
okay
so for that I'm writing here
comma
okay
then text equals to
re Dot substring
comma
comma text
okay
then I have to write text equals to
r e Dot substring
www
Dot
S Plus
comma
from our text
okay then text equals to
re Dot substring
then
oh
comma
okay
then
text equals to
re Dot substring
and
percentage
as
again percentage or
RG dot SK function
right here string
dot punctuation
comma
and comma then text
right
then text equals to re Dot substring
and n
comma
text equal
re Dot
substring
right here
and again d
then again
then comma
and again
texture
okay then at the end after right here
return text
so everything like this these type of
special character will be removed from
the data set
okay let's run this let's see
yeah so here I will add DF sorry not DF
data
then
text
pursue
data
okay dot apply
to the function name wordpot word opt
okay
press enter
yeah so now let's define the dependent
and independent variables okay x equals
to
data
text
and Y equals to
data
class
okay
then splitting training and testing data
okay sorry
so here I will write X underscore train
comma X underscore test
uh then y underscore train
comma y underscore test equals to
train underscore test underscore split
then X comma y
comma test
let's go size equals to
0.25
okay press enter
so now let's convert text to vectors
for that I have to write here
that it's X
so here I will write from sqlarn
dot teacher
extraction
Dot text import
t
vectorizer
okay
then vectorization
plus 2 tfid
factorizer
okay
then
it's V
underscore
train
equals to
vectorization
the ion refactorization dot fit
that transform
X underscore train
okay
then XV underscore test equals to
characterization
Dot transform
X underscore test
okay then press enter
[Music]
so now let's see our first model
logistic regression
so here I will write
from
sqlan Dot
linear underscore model
okay import
logistic
regression
then a lot equals to
logistic
regression
and
after that here LR Dot
fit
then XV
Dot
not DOT so dot train
comma
x v underscore test
okay
press enter
dot XV dot train
here I have to write y train
and press enter
it will work so here I will write
prediction
underscore
linear regression
l r dot predict
XV underscore test
okay let's see the accuracy score
for that I have to write l r dot score
then XV underscore test
comma y underscore test
okay
let's see the accuracy so here as you
can see accuracy is quite good 98
percent
now let's print
the classification
port
by underscore test comma
prediction of linear regression
okay
so this is you can see Precision score
then F1 is code then support value
accuracy
okay
so now we will do this same for the
decision free gradient boosting
classifier random for this classifier
okay then we will do model testing then
we will predict this code
so now for the decision tree
classification so for that I have to
import from SK learn
dot tree
import
decision
three
classifier
than at the short form I will write here
I will copy it from here
then
okay
then I have to write the same as this so
I will copy it from here
and
here
let's change linear regression
to
season 3 classified
okay
then I will write here same
let's go DT
question
DT dot predict
sweet underscore
test
e
still loading it's it will take time
okay
till then let me write here for the
accuracy
DOT score
three underscore test
comma y
let's wait okay
let's run
the accuracy
so as you can see accuracy is good than
this linear regression
okay logistic regression
okay so let me
show you the
let me predict
trend
okay
so this is the accuracy score this is
the all the report
yeah
so now let's move for the gradient
boosting classifier
okay for that I've read from
sqlan
dot ensemble
port
gradient
boosting
classifier
pacifier
I will write here GB
equals to let me copy it from here
I will give here random
let's go state
equals to zero
wait wait wait wait so I will write here
g b Dot
fit
underscore train
comma
y underscore trade okay then press enter
so here I will write predict
underscore GB
also
GB Dot
wait sorry
Reddit
three
Dot test
dot dot underscore test
till then it's loading so I will write
here uh it's for this code then I will
add GB
DOT score
then
three underscore test
comma
y underscore test
okay
so let's wait it is running this part
till then let me write for the printing
this
okay it's taking time
taking time still taking time
but if I will run this
it's not coming because of this
yeah it's done now so you can see the
accuracies
not good then
decision tree but yeah it is also good
.4 something okay so
now let's check for the last one random
Forest
first I will do
for the random for us we have to write
from sqlan Dot
symbol
import
random
Forest
classified
okay
and here I will write RF
equals to
right I will copy it from here
then
random
date
equals to
zero
then
RF Dot
fit
three underscore train
comma y underscore train
okay then press enter
and predict
underscore
RC
or F
equals to
RF dot predict
three underscore test
okay
till then I will write it still loading
it will take time
so till then I will write for this score
score accuracy score
x v underscore test comma y underscore
test
okay
then I will write here till then print
classification
port
and Y underscore test
comma
it will take time little bit
so
it run the accuracy score is 99 it is
also good
so now I will add the code for the model
testing so I will get back to you
but after writing the code so
so I have made two functions one for the
output label and one for the manual
testing okay
so it will predict
the all the from the all models from the
repeat so it will predict
the the news is fake or not from all the
models okay
so for that
let me write
here news
also string
what
okay
then I will write a manual underscore
testing
so
here I will you can add any news from
the you can copy it from the Internet or
whatever from wherever you want
so I'm just copying from the internet
okay from the Google
the news
which is not fake okay I'm adding which
is not fake because I already know I
searched on Google so I'm entering this
so just run it let's see what is showing
okay
string input object is not callable okay
let me check this first
okay I have to give here Str only
yeah check
okay I have to add here again the Escape
yeah
manual testing is not defined
let me see manual testing
okay I have to edit something
it is just GB and it is just RF
in GPS is not defined okay okay
so what I have to do
I have to remove this
this
everything seems sorted
now
as I said to you
I just copied this news from the
internet I already know the news is not
fake so it is showing not a fake news
okay so now what I will do I will copy
one fake news from the internet
and let's see it is detecting it or not
okay
so let me run this
and let me add the news for this
so
all the models are predicting right it
is a fake news
or you can add your own script like this
is the fake news okay
I hope you guys understand
till here
so I hope you guys must have understand
how to detect a fake news using machine
learning you can you can copy it any
news from the internet and you can check
it is fake or not on that note if you
are an expiring eiml engineer there is
no better time to train yourself in the
exciting field of machine learning if
you are looking for a course that covers
everything from fundamentals to Advanced
Techniques like machine learning
algorithm development and unsupervised
learning look no further than our
Caltech in partnership with IBM this AI
ml bootcampment collaboration with
Caltech will help you advance your
career as an AIML specialist the AIML
bootcamp includes live classes delivered
by industry experts Hands-On lab
Industries 11 projects and master
classes by Caltech Professor key
features of this amazing machine
learning course include and up to 22 cus
from caltex crtma online convocation by
Caltech ctme program director simply
runs Career Services helps you get
noticed by top hiring companies earn a
bootcamp certificate from caltex ctma 25
plus Hands-On projects across industry
verticals to integrated lab so why wait
join now seats are filling fast and the
find the course link from the
description box below
so in today's session we will go through
what hate speeches after that a
hands-off live demo of how to detect
hate speech using machine learning we
will perform different function and
different python libraries
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss hate speech and
proceed further for the same
so what is head speech any speech that
dispersed a group of people because of
their race religion nationality national
origin sexual or detention or gender
identity is considered as hate speech
hate speech is frequently used to
promote purgatory and hatred
additionally it can be applied to
threaten and intimate others
people may experience loneliness anxiety
and fear as a result
hate crimes may also result from it
additionally hate speech can harm
between various racial and ethnic groups
it is crucial to identify hate speech
using since doing so can assist in
stopping these negative impacts real
Learners if you want to upskill your AI
and machine learning skills so give
yourself a chance to Simply learn
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
the completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box below
so here is one question for you guys I
will give you exactly one minute for
this you can comment or you can give
your answer in the chat section so I can
see if the answers given by you are
right or wrong I'm repeating again there
is one question for you I will give you
exactly one minute for this you can
comment or you can give your answer in
the chat section so I I can see if your
answer given by your right or wrong
so the question is
all keywords in Python are
capitalized lowercase
uppercase and none
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
so I am starting the timer of one minute
okay
the time start now to let me know your
answers please
just type your answer in the comment
section or in the chat section
all python keywords are in
capitalize lowercase uppercase none
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
30 seconds remaining
all keywords in Python are capitalized
lowercase uppercase or none
the second small
all keywords in Python are capitalized
lowercase uppercase and none
let us know your answer in the comment
section below please
five seconds more
after the allotted time has passed Those
Who provided the correct response will
receive a response and those Who
provided the incorrect response will
receive one
so now let's move to our programming
part
first we will open command prompt to
write a command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
Center
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and here you have to go new
python
this is the how the Jupiter kernel look
likes
so here
as we will import some major libraries
or python which will help in analyzing
the data so here I will write import
ance
as PD
import
numpy
as NB
then from
Escalon
section
or text
counter vectorizer
okay
then one more from
still learn
model selection
test underscore split
then from Escalon
Audrey
import
ant
okay
counter vectorizer
account vectorizer it is
so numpy is a python Library used for
working with array it also has a
function for working with the domain of
linear algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stand for numerical
python
and pandas pandas is a software Library
written for the Python programming
language for data manipulation and
Analysis in particular it offers data
structure and operation for manipulating
numerical tables and Time series
this count vectorizer a fantastic
utility offered by the python
scikit-learn module is count vectorizer
it is used to convert a given text into
a vector base on the number of times
like count that each word appears across
the full text
train test split
so our data is separated into train and
testing data using the trend as a split
Technique we must first separate our
data into features X and label y divided
into X strain X text y train and Y test
the data frame is the model is trained
and fitted using extend and white chain
sets okay then this is entry a
supervised machine learning algorithm
called decision tree uses a set of
principles to make judgments much like
how people do
okay move forward let's import some more
libraries
so here I will write import
Ari then import
lltk
then from
ltk Dot
I will write here stammer
equals to nltk
Dot
mobile
in English
form nltk
purpose
upwards
okay then we'll write import
string
and I will assign stop word
equals to set
words
and English
okay
the function in the module allow you to
determine whether a given text fills a
given regular expression which is known
as a regular expression or radical or if
a regular expression matches a
particular string which comes down to
the same thing
the nltk toolkit was created for python
users to deal with NLP it offers us
numerous test data as data set and
different text processing libraries
using an ltk a range of activities can
be carried out including tokenizing and
visualizing parse trees
snowball stammer the stemming algorithm
also refers to as Porter 2 streaming
algorithm
is an improved version of potent stammer
because some of its shortcomings have
been addressed
okay so stop word a stop word is
frequently used term that a search
engine has been considered
both while indexing items for searching
and when retrieving them as a result of
search query
then import string
it is used to determine whether or not
substring is part of the main string it
gives back a pointer to the first
instance of S2 in S1 I hope you guys
understand till here okay if you have
any queries any question regarding this
please comment down below
so after importing libraries let's
import our data set so I will write here
TF
close to
PD Dot
data set name Twitter
or data
Okay so
print
so this is the Twitter data set you can
download it from the description box
below and if you want to see the last
five rows instead of top five rows you
can use tail instead of head okay
moving forward I will add a new column
to this data set as labels which will
contain the values as headspace detected
offensive language detected or no hate
no offensive language detected
okay
for that I have to write here
DF
map
which
today
the third one is
the column so here I will add DF Dot
hat
let's see
we have added labels
okay offensive logins
moving forward now I will only select
the tweet and the label column for the
rest of the task obtaining a hate speech
detection model okay so here I will
write DF equals to d f
after that tweet
foreign
tweet
comma
labels
right here DF dot head
as you can see
it okay so moving now I will create a
function to clean the text in the Tweet
column like this
that at the rate and this exclamation
each type of words
so here I will add
BF clean
next
text
equals to
Str
x equals to
three Dot substring
Dash this Dot
question mark
then
come on
and I will write here text equals to
re Dot substring
https
Plus
then
www
Plus
big comma
come on
text
okay here I will write text
is to re Dot
subscribe
dot start
us
comma
next here then let me
so here I will add text equals to
re Dot substring
page
dot punctuation
here again text equals to
read Dot substring
then
passion
for the next line
comma
blue no d
w
[Music]
x
equals to
it's
called and stopper
that's equal to
turn
and I will add DF then column in tweet
to DF
we have to implant
so everything will be clean like this
let me run it
okay
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding any code so please comment
down below so everything is sorted now
everything is clean
okay so moving forward now let's split
the data set into training and test that
and train a machine learning model for
the task of edit speech
okay so here I will write x equals to
P dot array
then DF
right
we Dot
Eddie
then DF
found
equalizer
here I will add x equals to
CV dot fit
for transform
X
okay
here I will write X underscore trained
underscore test
again
underscore
test
X form of Y comma
phase
equals to
the state will be
35 equals to
BC
I will write classifier Dot
with
okay let me run it
okay d
f
a season 3 classifier sorry my bad
input contains an n
okay there is one empty
it's working
so
moving forward now let's test this
machine learning model to see if it is
detecting say it is speech or not okay
so here I will write test
underscore
yeah
okay
so I will give one sentence here like
I
and DF equals to
transform
test underscore data
today
then here I will print
classifier
as you can see
latest speech is detected because I will
kill you there is something hate on that
so let me write another sentence here
like
you
may run it
so here you can see no hate and
offensive speech you are awesome
so
private another one
like you
okay press enter
so here you can see it is not hit speed
but offensive language
okay
I hope you guys must have understand how
you can return hate this piece using
machine learning if you have any queries
you can ask in the comment section below
our team will respond as soon as
possible
so in today's session we will discuss
what image classification is and moving
ahead we will discuss what CNN is and at
the end we will do a hands of lab demo
of image classification using CNN
so before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what image
classification is and proceed further
for the same what is image
classification
the process of classifying an entire
image is known as image classification
images are anticipated to have just one
class per image models for image
classification taken an image as input
and produce a prediction of the class to
which the image belongs
so we can utilize image classification
models when we are not interested in
individual instance of items with
position information or their shape
so let's see what is CNN
machine learning includes convolutional
neural networks also known as convents
or cnns it is a subset of the several
artificial neural network models that
are employed for diverse purpose and
data sets a CNN is a particular type of
network design but deep learning
algorithm that is utilized for tasks
like image recognition and pixel data
processing and so more
okay
although there are different kinds of
neural network in deep learning
cnns are preferred neural architect for
identifying and recognizing object
therefore they are really suited for
computer vision activities and
application where accurate object
recognition is crucial
such as facial and self-driving
automatic system so moving ahead
so dear Learners if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skills so
give yourself a chance to Simply and
professions certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with a
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course out details from the
description box below so now let's move
to our programming part of how to do
image classification using CNN if
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
the first way we will open a command
prompt to write a command to open
Jupiter notebook so here we will write
Jupiter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook so here you can select new
python file
so this is how the Corners look like
okay Jupiter notebook colors look like
so first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in like analyzing the data okay so in
this file we will classify small images
of cifar 10 data set from tensorflow
Krrish data set there are total 10
classes as shown below so we will use
CNN for the classification purpose okay
so here I will write import
tensorflow
as TF
okay so from
tensorflow
dot Keras
import
data sets
from our layers
of models
okay so we will import
numpy as NP
right and import
matplotlib
as
PLT
right okay so here I will add Buy plot
as PLT
right so tensorflow this one
this
so tensorflow is a free and open source
machine learning and artificial
intelligence software Library
it can be used for variety of
applications
but it focuses on mainly deep neural
network training and the influence
purpose okay got it
and this numpy numpy is a python Library
used for working with the arrays it also
has a function for working with the
domain of lineal algebra and matrices it
is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stand for numerical
python
and this third one matplotlib
for Python and its numerical extension
numpy matplotlib is a cross-platform
data visualization and a graphical
charting package as a result it presents
a strong open source substitute for
Matlab the apis application programming
interfaces format plot live allow
programmers to incorporate graphs into
GUI applications
got it
so let's run this
let me change image
classification
using
CNN
okay
so let's load the data set okay we will
load the data set from the uh
load data function
so here I will write
X
underscore
train
comma why underscore okay
okay
and one for test X
underscore test comma y underscore test
okay then equals to data set
result sets dot we are using Cipher 10.
C for 10.
for 10.
dot load
Dot
underscore
data okay
so it will load our data so let's load
the data
so data is loaded let's see X
let's go
test dot shape
okay
yeah
so as you can see
so we have thousand
rows and one more X
underscore train
dot ship
let me run this
so here you can see
like we see like training data
like training images are 50 000 and the
test images are
10 000 okay
so this is for testing this is for
training and
so moving ahead we will see for the Y
train
dot shape
1000 and here we will see the array so y
underscore train
five
okay let's send this first let me give
some space yeah
so here y underscore train is a 2d array
like for our classification having 1D
arrays are good enough
so what we will do we will convert this
to now 1D array this is 2D array we will
convert into 1D array okay for that
we'll write here y underscore train
was to Y underscore train
dot reshape
minus one comma
then why underscore train
and again semicolon 5.
let's run this
okay so now this is 1D array
so
y underscore test
equals to Y underscore test
Dot
reshape
n minus 1
here I will write
classes
there are some classes okay in the data
set like airplane
comma
automobile
but
comma
cat
here
dog
yeah
course
step
the truck
okay
so these are the some classes
like airplane automobile bird cat deer
so it will be helping classifying the
images
so let's plot some images to see like
what they are what they exactly are okay
so we will what we will do we will
create one function
for that
let me write here
def plot underscore sample
yeah then X comma y
comma index
okay
then I will write here plot dot figure
PLT dot figure
then figure size should be
comma 2
equals to
pld dot show
image show to IM show
X
index
PLT
dot X label
classes
y index okay
so let's see some samples of the images
so I will write a plot
underscore sample
uh underscore train
comma y underscore train
okay comma let's see the fifth image
okay then enter
would be capital
so as you can see this is a car so it is
showing automobile okay
so let's see once more
like plot underscore sample
X underscore train
comma y underscore test
comma we'll see the tenth one
here it is not quite visible
so we'll go for the 11
okay
okay I am
white is showing wrong because I use a
test I have to use here train instead of
test
then it will show I think correct yeah
you can see horse the nodes
then what about
201 image
see you can see
so we will see once more
Fancy Frog okay it's not quite visible
yeah so you can see here
the proper ship okay
so what we will do now we will normalize
the images to a number from 0 to 1.
image has three channels like RGB colors
so and each value in the channel can
range from 0 to 255. hence to normalize
in 0 to 1 range we need to divide it by
255 okay
so
now what we will do we will normalize
the data
so here what we'll do at X underscore
train
equals to
X underscore train
divided by
255 and 0.
okay
and same for test
question test
divided by
255.0
okay to range between 0 to 1.
we will build simple artificial neural
network for image classification first
okay
so we will write here a n n
equals to models Dot sequential
okay then I will write here
layers
Dot
platen
input underscore
shape equals to
32 comma 32. comma 3.
okay
then again layers dot tens
comma activation
got it
and again for the Thousand so I will
what I will do I will copy it
and paste it here okay
thousand
so let me add one more one more layer
dot tens
then
we'll add 10 comma
activation
also softmax
okay
here I will okay let me give for the
better visuals
yeah
so a n
n dot compile
optimizer
okay
equal to
SGD
and comma
I will write a loss
equals to
sparse
categorical
cross entropy
okay
so here I will add comma then Matrix
equals to
accuracy
a n
dot fit
underscore train
comma y underscore train
comma epochs
okay
so number I will give you box equals to
five
right
so it will take time to run
which is stunning
here there is some issue
underscore train
it box equation
five
what it is saying
when user code the file program C
engine okay
you will copy it
and paste it again
run it again
okay now it's working
okay
so it will take time and then I will get
back to you okay
then import
numpy you guys already know what numpy
is
NP
y underscore prediction
NN dot predict
X underscore test
okay then why underscore
prediction underscore
classes
equals to
NP Dot
argument Max
element
or
in
y underscore prediction
print
classification
both
comma classification
let's go report
then y
underscore test comma y underscore
prediction
underscore
classes
okay
so let me run this
capital
yeah
it will take less time
now we will create a graph
okay
like X text is like we have thousand
images so CLA graph will be like messed
up
still let's see
so I'd like to import
c bond as SNS
okay
c bond
yeah
let me give some space
here I will write PLT Dot
bigger
because
I should be
10 comma seven
okay then as soon as we will create a
heat map for this
and Y underscore prediction
not question
true
then PLT dot y label
this truth
alt dot X label
fiction
than PLT dot title should be
using
okay then PLT dot show
let me run this
okay
see why prediction has X text
it's still running
let's wait
so now let's make CNN model okay to
train our images so for that I will add
CNN equals to
models Dot
sequential
okay
yeah so let me run this
so this is our CNN model from which we
will train our images
and CNN like compile
then
optimize
optimizer
equals to
Adam
okay
comma
right here then loss
equals to
ours
categorical
you then cross
entropy
okay
and comma
I will write here Matrix
equals to
curacy
we run this
okay
those
yeah
same goes for you
okay loss
and I do I will rewrite this
okay now let's check CNN model
for the 10 epox
okay
let's see the accuracies increasing or
not
CNN
it's called train
comma y underscore train
comma
box
also
it is started
it will take less time than the previous
one
okay
see
you want this whole code
you can comment down the same
okay
so after completing this I will get back
to you
so it is almost done like 27 seconds
with a 10 epochs
till then let me write CNN dot evaluate
underscore test
comma y underscore test
okay
so with CNN the N5 epox accuracy was
around like 70 percent and which is a
significant improvement over a n okay
and then we have like just 49
okay and cnns are the best for image
classification and gives the superb
accuracy also computation is the much
less compared to simple a n as Max
pooling reduces the image Dimension
while still uh preserving these features
okay so let me run this
um
take some time
till then I will write y underscore
prediction
equals to CNN
Dot
predict
and X underscore test
okay
then I will write a y underscore
prediction
then column five
let me run this
so you can see the accuracy and all the
array
okay
it's
yeah
so let's
class is equal to
NP Dot ERG Max
element
or
element in
y prediction
then why underscore classes
then
these are the number of classes then y
underscore test
is column five
these are the array
so it's converted into array then
now let's see the it is predicting Right
image or wrong image okay by not with
the training data here we predict from
the training data while training extend
okay now we will predict from the test
data so here I will add plot
underscore sample
then
X underscore test comma y underscore
test
and you can write
these random one
so here I will write 60
let's see so you can easily see here
this is odds and it is predicting right
horse
and let me
okay
plot
sample
then X underscored test comma y
underscore test
comma
okay
press enter
okay X is capital
yeah
so you can see this is Dr
okay so our model is predicting the
correct
image okay then what we like
let's see it is predicting the right
class or not okay we made the classes
like random classes
okay where are these these so let's see
it is predicting right or wrong
okay for that I have to write classes
y underscore classes
like which number 60. okay
60.
so 60 is not defined because like number
of classes
okay okay
there are one two three four five six
seven
okay zero to nine I can choose
so here what I will do
I will take small one
I get five
okay this is frog
okay
it's rock right
so I will take instead of 60 here I will
see frog
okay y class is not defined
by underscore classes
is defined see okay there are three s
yeah
so as you can see frog this is frogs so
our classes depending right so here I
will write it again like
it was horse
and let me write here 60.
you can see the right prediction okay
so
this is what how you can you do image
classification using CNN I hope you guys
must have understood this concept like
how to do image classification using CNN
on that note if you are an expiring AIML
engineer there is no better time to
train yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you are looking for
a course that covers everything from
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our Caltech in partnership
with IBM this AI ml bootcampment
collaboration with Caltech will help you
advance your career as an AIML
specialist the AIML bootcamp includes
live classes delivered by industry
experts Hands-On lab Industries 11
projects and master classes by Caltech
Professor key features of this amazing
machine learning course include and up
to 22 cus from caltex citme online
convocation by Caltech ctme program
director simply runs Career Services
helps you get notice but top hiring
companies earn a bootcamp certificate
from caltex ctma 25 plus Hands-On
projects across industry verticals to
integrated lab so why wait join now
seats are filling fast and the find the
course link from the description box
below in today's session we will go
through what is movie recommendation
system after that we will see how movie
recommendation system work moving
forward we will see filtering strategies
for movie recommendation system and at
the end we will see Hands-On lab demo
like how to create movie recommendation
system using python in detail we already
have data set with us we will perform
different function and Implement a movie
recommendation system using python
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what is movie
recommendation system actually is and
proceed further for the same
so renting CDs and DVDs reading local TV
listenings watching film strip
projectors or recordings all of this is
a thing of the past today
all of the world's biggest film
collection have been digitized and moved
to the online streaming services like
Netflix HBO or YouTube
these platform can now help us with what
is possibly the most difficult task of
all choosing a movie they have been
announced with AI powered capabilities
well that is no longer a concern for you
it is final time for machine learning to
put its skills on display in the modern
cinematic landscape
to create Advanced predictive system for
True movie expert data scientists are
prepared to investigate our behavioral
patterns and those of movies
a movie recommendation system also known
as a movie recommender system uses
machine learning to predict or filter
user fill preferences based on their
prior decision and actions it is an
advanced filtration system that
anticipate the consumer in question
potential like selection for a domain
specific item a movie
so after seeing what is movie
recommendation system let's move forward
and see how movie recommendation system
actually works a movie recommendation
system fundamental idea is a pretty
straightforward every recommender system
primarily consists of two components
users and items user receive more
prediction from the system and the
actual movies are the products filtering
and predicting only the movies that a
matching user is most likely to wish to
see in the main objective of movie
recommendation system the user
information from the system database is
used by the ml algorithm for these
recommendation system
based on information from the past this
data is used to forecast the user in
questions behavior in the future
data should be handled by expert because
it is so crucial to ml projects
including the movie recommendation
system
after seeing how movie recommendation
system works let's see some filtration
strategies for movie recommendation
system
to assist user in finding the most
relevant films movie recommendation
system employ a variety of filtration
techniques and algorithm
the content-based filtering and the
collaborative filtering system
subcategories of the ml algorithm used
for the movie recommendations are the
most well liked ones
filtering based on content or content
based filtering a method of filtering
movies in a movie recommendation system
that makes advantage of the item's data
this information which is taken from the
just one user is quite important in this
case
this technique uses an ml algorithm to
suggest movies that are comparable to
the user's past choices
therefore the information about the
prior movie choices and likes just one
person is used to generate similarity in
content-based filtering
and the second one is collaborative
filtering as the name implies this
filtering techniques is based on the
interaction between the relevant person
and the other user for the best outcomes
the system contrasts and compare these
behaviors it combines the film choices
and users patterns of several people
like there are two types of
collaborative filtering algorithm the
first one is collaborative filtering
based on users the goal is to find
patterns and Target users and other
database users like movie preferences
and the second one is collaborative item
based filtering the fundamental idea
behind this is to find comparable
products products like movies that
Target users rate or interact with so
after seeing the filtering strategies
for movie recommendation system so here
is one question for you guys
I will give you one minute for this you
can comment or you can give answer in
chat section so I can see if the answer
is given by you are right or wrong
I'm repeating again so here is one
question for you guys I will give you
one minute exactly one minute for this
you can comment or you can give your
answer in chat section so I can see if
the answers given by you are right or
wrong
so the question is which is the best
language for machine learning
programming
which is the best language for machine
learning the first one is Java the
second one is python the third one is
our language and the fourth one is C
plus plus
so this is the question I am repeating
again which is the best language for
machine learning
so option one is Java second python R
language and C plus plus
so I'm starting timer of one minute just
type your answers in comment section or
in a chat section do let me know your
answers
please I want that everyone should
participate in this and make this live
session interesting
so I am starting timer
oh your time starts now
please guys do let me know your answers
in chat section or in you can comment
down
42 seconds to go
you can comment or you can give your
answer in the chat section so I can see
if the answers given by you are right or
wrong
30 seconds more
which is the best language for machine
learning
you can give your answer chat section or
you can comment
so I can see if the answers given by you
are right or wrong guys come on please I
want that everyone should participate in
this and make this live section
interesting
one guys five second more
one
yep time up
so time is over we will give reply those
who gave correct answer and those who
didn't give correct answer we will give
you a reply with the correct answer
so now let's move to our programming
part to perform movie recommendation
system using python
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so we will write Jupiter
notebook press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select here new
new python file
so this is how jupyter notebook UI look
likes so at first we will import some
major libraries or python which will
help us in mathematical functioning so
so the first one is numpy import
numpy as NP
so number is a python Library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working in the domain of
lineal algebra and matrices it is an
open source project and you can use it
freely numpy stands for numerical python
so here NPD in NPS denoting numpy so we
will import the next Library
both pandas as
PD
this should be space yup
so
pandas is a software Library written for
the Python programming language for data
manipulation and Analysis in particular
it offers data structures and operation
for manipulating numerical tables and
time series so
so after importing libraries we will
move ahead and import data set so for
importing data set we have to write like
we have two data set with us
let me show you the data set we have two
data set with us
the first one is credits
this one
and the second one is movies one
movies one so don't worry you can get
this data set link in the description
box so let me write
here
credits
let's go data frame equals to PD dot
read
underscore CSV
here you have to give your location of
the data set
credits
dot CSV
the second one is movies
let's go data frame
this is for movie data frame PD dot read
ESP
so here you have to give the movie
location movie data set location movies
dot CSV
okay everything seems good
let me run this
yeah
so then
here PD is for the pandas Library read
is used for reading the data set from
the machine and CSV is used for the type
of file which you want to read so after
this let's write code to see the data
set so we will write here credits
underscore DF
and we will run it so this is our so
this is our credit data set and next one
is movies
underscore
so this is our movie data set
so this is how our board data set look
like so here you can see three dots
this one and here also
this one so we are unable to see our
full data set like what if we want like
full a 4803 rows
so at that case
we can write here
PD Dot
set
underscore option
okay
and here we will write display
dot Max
underscore columns
this
and here we will write none
same for the rows PD dot set
option
display
dot Max
underscore rows
okay
none
let's run this
so now if we will write credits
underscore DF
it is running yeah
so now you can see your full data set
like full credit data set with 4803 rows
or four eight zero two rows because
there is
this is starting from 0 that's why so
what about movies data set
give it running
it is still running you can see here
so here you can see the full data set
movie data set with 4802 rows
or if you want to see only five top rows
so you can write here credits underscore
DF dot head
so by this only five top rows so from
head you we can see our five top rows
and if we will use tail instead of head
we can see our last five rows so here
let me do with the movies one
DF Dot
tail
yeah
so here you can see four seven nine
eight row four seven nine and till four
eight zero two so with tail we can see
our last five rows
so moving forward let's merge the credit
data set to movie data set because if we
will combine them the confusion will be
less and at the end it will be better
for us so we will write here movies
underscore
equals to movies
underscore data frame and credits
underscore DF
on
it
okay T is small I guess yeah perfect
Titan
so let me do something something like
this
okay
it is saying data frame object is not
callable
edits underscore PF
please
okay why because
we haven't wrote merge here
now it will work
yeah perfect it's working so data is
merged let's see the number of rows and
column using share function so now we
have only one so movies underscore DF
dot shape
okay let's run it 4809 and 2 3 23 but if
we see here like in movies data set so
in movies data set here here yeah yeah
there are 20 and
in here we are four columns in credit
data set
so
like so you will be thinking that's why
not 24 why only 23 columns that is why
on title you can see here on title the
titles in both titles are same you can
see here
both titles are same
in both
okay let me show you like this okay
after Pirates of the Caribbean Spectra
and so on
here you can see after pirates of the
academy inspector and so on
so that is why on title written while
merging so title are same so moving
forward let's see our merge data set
so we will write only movies
underscore data frame dot head
yeah
so our data is merged you can see
the last cast crew movie ID yeah you can
see here movie ID title are the same
they are most cast crew okay guys
let me give some more
for the better View
yeah
so you can see all Columns of credit
data set are added to movies one so
moving forward let's see another
function like
movies
underscore DF Dot info
so by this
yes you can see
so by this the data frame information is
printed via the info method the data
includes the total number of columns
their labels data kinds memory use rage
index and the number of cells in each
columns like non-null values note that
info method does indeed print the
information
so here you can see the all the
information is printed
okay
like columns name and the all null
values count and data types to like this
int object and
in which we are working most so after
this let's move forward and select some
main column in which you are working
most so we will write movies
underscore DF equals to movies
underscore DF
title
comma and another one is overview
okay why
okay here we have to like this
yeah
so here we have to write John R
Jonah is complete and we will work on
what keywords keywords are the main
keywords okay keywords then
it will cost
then we will
we will do recommendation with the crew
as well
okay
so by running this let me see
our data again with seven okay okay
there is one error okay this is movie
the movie The Idea yeah not index okay
got it got it
why not Jonah
it's Jonas I guess
what it is it's John it's
that's why
it's Jonas okay
yeah so let's see our data again with
seven columns so I will write so I will
write here movies underscore DF
dot head
here
so you can see only our we have like
movies ID same title overview genres
keywords cars and crew only
so here you can see the selected columns
okay so let's move forward and once
again let's see the info again like
movies
underscore TF Dot
invoice come with selected columns and
let's move forward and see how many
missing values are present in particular
column so like the columns is full we
can see here but we don't know about
that four thousand eight zero three
values are filled or not so what we will
do it we will see how many missing
values are present there so
here we will write like movies
underscore DF dot is null
dot sum
not like this
yeah perfect
so the function data frame is null this
one is null dot sum dot sum Returns the
number of missing values in the data set
so here you can see overview have three
missing values
so what we can do is we can write here
movies
underscore DF
DF
Dot
drop n a
this
equals to
true
okay
we will run it with sayings okay words
documents
also true okay fine
and yeah it will not create an issue so
if you sat in place equals to true the
drop any method will modify your data
frame directly that means that if you
set in place equals to true the drop any
will drop all missing values from your
original data set let's move forward and
see movies
underscore DF
Dot
duplicated
so the duplicate method returns a series
with true on false
values that describe which rows in the
data frame are duplicated or not use the
subset parameter to specify if any
column should not be considered when
looking for duplicates
so
here let me run this first
so here we are we are getting 0. y 0 so
if you are like thinking there is no
true or false return so if you write it
without sum like if I will write it
without some
okay let me copy from here yeah and I
will run this so
here you can see
false false false in whole data set
so some will combine them and return you
a value at the end zero represent false
itself
so we need to not need this so we will
write something else
so moving forward let me write First
movies
underscore TF dot I location
Dot johnnets
let me run this
so the I log function this one ilock
function
first let me do something like this
it will go up okay huh
Okay so
from ilog function in Python is defined
in the pandas module that helps us to
select a specific row or column from the
data set
using the ilock method in Python we can
easily retrieve any particular value
from a row or column by using index
value so here zeroth position line is
coming
which is here you can see
so name action like name action name
Adventure name fantasy this PSI
physician
this one science fiction yeah so this is
because I am giving here Jonah that is
why you can see here
see id28 name action name something
something like that okay
so
let's import something called ASG
abstract syntax Factory
so this is one of the major Library
import AST
let me run this import is a class
defined is the AST module that is used
to express the import statement in
python in the form of abstract syntax
tree so
so an abstract syntax tree or just
syntax tree is a tree representation of
the of the abstract syntactic structure
of text written in a formal language
each node of the trade denotes a
construct occurring in the text
so let's convert some like literal to
object and append them so here I will
write Def
convert
obj object
like l
equals to
blank array
for I in
St Dot
control
bit
object
okay
l dot append
return
here we are converting is like here is a
convert is a function and L is the array
to append by using for Loop we can
append them to name so let me write code
then I will explain like what is
happening so let me write full code so
movies
underscore TF
donors
okay
because your movies
to honors
and then dot apply
what
so then movies underscore TF
then I will write keywords
let's do movies
underscore DF
keywords
bye
Discord DF Dot
foreign
and that's keyword this keyword
apps ID name and so on like ID that name
like this type of things so it will
create a message retrieving them so by
using AST Library we just convert them
to the normal one like title so got it
guys so I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or question
just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
abbreviating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
type of questions regarding any code or
something
so just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
so moving forward let's convert cash to
and like same as previous way like like
this only so what we will do here we
will write f
convert
em
here I am using
so l equals to
counter equals to zero
St
dot literal
if counter
does not
equals to 3
then
l dot
dot append okay then here you have to
write I
to name
counter
equals to 1.
if you want to write like count as
equals to counter plus one it is like
both the same
else
click
done
l
so let me run this
let me run this
okay so after this is small code we have
to assign the values like
we are doing it for Costner so movies
okay moves let's go DF then cast
let's show movies
underscore DF
asked
Dot
reply
convert
everything seems good
so let's see the changes are visible or
not so we will write here movies
underscore TF dot hat
you can ignore this like this is nothing
so here you can see cast is also
same like keyword and journal
so like let's do for the creo2
so like we are converting you can say in
a structured way
so let's do for the crew one two so let
me put some
yeah
so here we will add depth like fetch
which is nothing like
a function name flash director
obj
okay
colon l equals to
or I
n s t Dot literal
obj
if
I
like job
also is equals to
like we can hit director
so then
l dot append
I'll dot append
um
dot append to the same name
but
return
okay capital l
so we have to again write that movies
video
equals to movies
in crew
lie
h
just remember fetch director is a
function name let's see changes
so here I have to write movies then
press enter
so yeah crew is all set so
changes are visible and data is looking
good so what we
like if I want to see the first movie
Avatar overview this like this dot dot
dot so I have to write here
like movies
overview
Overview at 0th place
so yeah
so this is a full overview of avtar
movie like let me read for this in this
2017 Century uh paraplegic Marine is
dispatched and blah blah blah blah and
civilization
so moving forward that what we want to
recommend movie in the basis of overview
genre keyword cars so for that we need a
separate separate words like in the then
22nd century alone
so if you will see in other columns all
the words are separated but like here if
you will see all the words are separated
like action is subtracted Adventure is
updated fantasy it's separated
so
there is a long sentence in this this
one in the overview one these are long
sentence
so it's difficult to recommend from this
so what we are going to do is well we
will separate them like like other
columns so here we will write
movies
overview
let's do movies
and overview
and Dot apply
my bad sorry
then Lambda
colon x dot
split
error so let's see the results
so movies
yeah you can see in the Saturn so now
you can see all the words are separated
by comma so now it will easy to match
overview to recommend a particular movie
so moving forward so what we are going
to do is if there is a two word and
space between there so we are going to
remove that space so here you can see
science fiction are separate separate
okay so we are going to re like remove
this one this is space
so let's write code for that
so here I will write like
overview is already done so we will do
not do for that so let's write code for
the rest columns
so here I have to write
movies
like
genres
pursue movies
and again
Jonas
not apply
Lambda
X
I dot replace
Ma
to no space
oh it seems good
then I have to write for
everywhere so for I in x
it's for I in x 4 I in x
movies genres equals to movie genres dot
apply Lambda X
I dot replace this to this for
James code
so let's copy paste this see
one for keywords and one for cast and
crew
asked
first
that you
that's the same so let me run this
okay no error seems good so let's see
the changes so movies
yeah
so now you can see the science fiction
space is gone like here is science
fiction space is there
now science fiction space is gone
so like okay
let's move forward and create one new
column name as tag and put all the
column data in a particular column
okay let me do first yeah let me write
movies
this is a column one column name equals
to movies
then first we will put overview
less movies
and Jonas
and movies
and what we have to give keywords
keywords
then again
movies
then
asked
let me run this
okay
so let's see the data frame movies
okay still coming so like there is one
problem I guess
yeah no no no
so here you can see all the data is
merged in a under attack column yes you
can see like in the second century blah
blah blah so
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding any code
or anything just put as in comment or
our team will shortly provide you the
correct solution okay so I'm repeating
again I hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code or like any
question just put as in comment our team
will shortly provide you the correct
solution
so from here let's create a new data
frame
so let me create new data frame because
now we don't need this overview car
screw Joiner like columns like this we
have already merged into a one one
column like attack column so we will
write here new
DF equals to movies
so
like movies we need movie ID
new data frame we need movie ID comma we
need Title
and we have everything in tag column tax
column so we need tax column
okay let's run this let's see our new
data frame
so this is our new data look likes with
only three columns like movie ID title
and tags so here you can see array
brackets like this this error brackets
so
we are gonna remove them so we will do
what we will write here we will write
new
data frame
that n tags
equals to
new
data frame
tags
dot apply
Lambda
X
then I will give space
dot join
themes good everything is okay okay fine
yeah
so let's see the results so
we will write a new underscore data
frame
so you can see the brackets are removed
now let's see the data which is present
in the zeroth index in tag column like
this dot dot in this
okay for that we have to write here
a new
data frame
tax
we did it before like for the overview
one so you have to yeah
so this is the whole data in the first
like first index 0th index so some part
of the overview like from civilization
and some are you can see this action
adventure fantasy science fiction these
are some like genres
and
like here you can see like these are
some Crews members and
yeah like Sam Worthington like there are
some cast crew okay
so like moving forward like what we are
going to do is just make them in lower
case for the better prediction like
something in capital and something like
smaller so let's make it to
lowercase so new underscore DF
tax
equals to new underscore DF
tags
dot apply
column X
dot lower
okay
so don't worry about this error
let's see the result uh new underscore
DF
Dot
yeah now all the data present at TAG
column is in small case or you can say
lowercase moving forward let's do some
feature extraction using count
vectorizer so let let me write first
from SK learn
Dot feature
instruction
feature extraction okay cool
dot text
import
count
vectorizer
GV equals to
count
riser
X underscore
features
equals to
5000.
oh
words
equals to
English
and this
yeah
so count vectorizer
okay there is a
that cannot import count vectorizer from
SQL and from user
okay okay sorry sorry my bad here V is
capital
okay guys so he be his Capital yeah so
no error so count vectorizer is a great
tool provided by the scikit-learn
library in Python it is used to
transform a given text into a vector on
the basis of the frequency count
of each word that occurs in the entire
text so
let me write something CV Dot
with underscore
transform
if
X like dot to array
shape
okay
so the fit method like learns a
vocabulary dictionary of all tokens in
the Raw documents that is it creates a
dictionary of tokens by default the
tokens are words separated by spaces and
like punctuation so that Maps e single
token to a position in the output Matrix
so here CVS are like here CV is a
counter vectorizer so let's convert into
Vector to array so for this we have to
write vectors
vectors equals to CV dot fit
okay then transform
X
in
so here we have to write
Dot
to array
yeah then we have to write
vector
its vectors
yeah you can see Vector 2 array all the
zeros
okay so moving forward let's get the
feature Name by writing
yeah so we will write here
Leanne LAN
chivi dot get
feature
names
okay then bracket
yeah
so okay we have like 500 feature names
so I'm repeating I'm saying again like I
hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding any code whatever it is so
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
okay guys like any code or you are not
understand anything just put as in
comment our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
so let's import some major Library which
is import
nltk
so what is nltk the natural language
toolkit nltk is a platform used for
building python programs that work with
human language
for applying in a statical network
language processing NLP it contain text
processing libraries for tokenization
parsing classification stemming tagging
and semantic reasoning
so moving forward like from let me write
first from
and
nltk
dot stem
dot Porter
import
ER
yes equals to
quarter
I mean is a process for reducing a word
to its word stem that suffix and prefix
or to the roots of words known as Alama
is timing is important in natural
language understanding nlu and natural
language processing NLP
so here like I have to write
so here I will write F stem
text
y
equals to
or I in
text Dot split
y dot append
s dot stem
done
dot join
y
so let's apply stemming to a tag column
so here we will write new DF
X
equals to
new
if
tag
dot apply
um
so let's import a cosine similarity from
SK learn so here we will write from SK
learn
dot matrices
Dot pairwise
import
cosine
underscore see me clarity
okay it seemed good from sqln matrices
metrics sorry Matrix Dot pairwise it is
[Music]
pairwise import cosine similarity okay
let's run this no error so cosine
similarity measures the similarity
between two factors
the similarity between two vectors of an
inner product space it is measured by
the cosine of the angle between two
vectors and determines whether two
vectors are pointing in roughly the same
direction
it is often used to measure document
similarity in text analysis so here we
will write
cosine
underscore see me
clarity
vectors
so these all are the vector present
let's see the cosine similarity Vector
column and row using space
so here I will write cosine
similarity
vectors
dot shape
so it's still running you can see here
yeah
so 4806 rows and four eight zero six
columns are there let's assign variable
similarity to this
okay so let's similarity
will write like this it might equals to
cosine
similarity
is underscore here
I did this because we don't have to
write always this long sentence
a long keyword you can say
so moving forward let's see First Column
like we will add similarity
yeah so this is our first column uh so
let's see the rows only so we will write
here
t
Dot
shape
okay 4806 okay
so let's move forward and let's create
some like sorted list so
for that sorted
okay
paste
enumerate
spelling is fine
okay one more like Simi laity
similarity
where I have to write reverse
equals to true
comma key
equals to Lambda
colon
x dot capital x x
to write 1
colon six
seems good yeah
so the enumerate function in Python
converts a data collection object into
an enumerate object enumerate returns an
object that contains a counter as a key
for each value with an object making
item within a collection easier to
access so finally let's create the
recommend function to check the movie
recommendation system
okay
so
so let's write here d f
recommend
we
also new
DF
in the TF
title
movie
X
zero
tenses
versus similarity
and movie
okay so movies
list equals to sorted
rate
already and rate
distances
reverse
pursue
true
keyword
sorry key only okay
equals to Lambda
colon X
and
colon six
or
I in movies
list
DF dot I lock
I
dot title we because we need Title only
so yeah it seems good okay
so finally that like time is game
so finally the time has come to check
the recommendation of your favorite
movies so you can comment in the chat
section so I can check
so let me write first recommend
recommend for movie
Avatar
okay
so here you can see the recommendation
system is working fine so Titan a DOT e
small soldier Independence Day are the
recommendation for the movie after so
let me check for the another one
recommend
like for
one of my favorite movie Iron Man
so here you can see Iron Man 2 Iron Man
3 Avengers Age of Ultron Captain America
and the Avengers are just
recommendations for the movie Iron Man
so let me check for the one more
recommend
layers
liar
things going on 30 and the last one is
last one I want to check is
Captain America Civil War
let me copy from here only
yeah you can see the Captain America the
First Avenger the Winter Soldier Iron
Man 3 age of ultron's The Avengers
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any query
regarding any code or question just put
us in comments our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution
on that note if you are an expiring AIML
engineer there is no better time to
train yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you are looking for
a course that covers everything from
fundamentals to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our Caltech in partnership
with IBM this AI ml bootcampment
collaboration with Caltech will help you
advance your career as an AIML
specialist the AIML bootcamp includes
live classes delivered by industry
experts Hands-On lab Industries 11
projects and master classes by Caltech
Professor key features of this amazing
machine learning course include and up
to 22 cus from caltex crtma online
convocation by Caltech ctma program
director simply runs Career Services
helps you get noticed by top hiring
companies earn a bootcamp certificate
from caltex ctma 25 plus Hands-On
projects across industry verticals to
integrated lab so why wait join now
seats are filling fast and the find the
course link from the description box
below
in today's session we will go through
what is text to speech converter after
that we will create text to speech
converter application using python this
we will create this one
we will perform different functions and
create amazing UI for application using
different python libraries before we
move on to the programming part let's
discuss what is text-to-speech converter
and proceed further for the same
text to speech is an API cloud service
that enables you to turn return text
into real sounding audio in a range of
languages and voices
by connecting with people in their own
language you can give your business a
voice and enhance customer experience
and engagement
increasingly accessibility of users of
diverse abilities offering audio
alternatives to prevent driving while
distracted or automating customer
service interaction to reduce hold items
let's move to our programming part to
create a text to speech converter
application using python
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open Jupiter notebook
so here we will write Jupiter
notebook
to open Jupiter notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of Jupiter
notebook and select open new python file
so this is how the Jupiter UI looks like
so at first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in creating UI and to convert text to
speech so the first one is
import
sorry import
EK enter
as TK
so TK enter is also known as TK
interface the default python interface
for TCL TK GUI toolkit is the TK enter
package or ticker interface
majority of unique System including Mac
OS as well as Windows machine support TK
and TK in turn
which is part of all common python
distribution is The Binding legal method
for creating graphical user interface
GUI in Python it is the only framework
included in the python standard library
in fact
so the next one is
first we will write here
import
sorry
from
PK enter
port
so from
PK enter
port
I
love
to file dialog TK enter provides a
number of built-in methods and class
Library function to create application
components and user actionable elements
one of the TK enter modules called file
dialog offers classes and Library
functions for making windows for
selecting files and dictionaries
when you need to request that a user
browser file or directory on the system
you can use file dialog
so the next one is
from
PK enter
Dot ttk
import
combo box
combo box combines an entry field and a
list box
one of the TK intervisits it has down
arrow to choose from a menu of
possibilities it adds consumer and
choosing from the list of available
options a pop-up of scrolling list box
is displayed down the entry field when
user clicks on the drop down arrow on
the entry field only when option from
the list box is selected will the select
option be shown in the enter field
this one is
it is one of the major One Import
py
t x
okay
so a python text to speech conversion
library is called pyts X3
it is compatible with python 2 and 3 and
works offline unlike Computing libraries
to obtain a reference to our pytx
library
an application called the pytic X3 init
Factory method it is a very user
friendly program that turns type text to
a speech
this amplifier for windows program
offers two voices that the pytdas X3
module supports a female voice and a
male voice three TTS engines are
supported by it Windows sappy i5 NSA
speech for Mac OS e-speak is available
on all other platform
so the next one is
import
OS
so the OS module in Python has function
for adding and deleting folders
retrieving their contents changing the
directory locating the current directory
and more before you can communicate with
the underlying operating system you must
import the OS module
the next one is
from
gtts
import
from
play sound
import
a sound
so gtts python has a variety of apis
that can turn text into speech the
Google text to speech API often known as
gtts API is one of these apis gtts is a
simple to use program that turns enter
text into audio that can be saved as MP3
file
languages including English Hindi Tamil
French German Spanish and many more are
supported via gtts API
any one of the two accessible audio
speeds Rapid or slow may be used to
deliver the speech device of created
audio however cannot be changed as the
most recent version
so let me run this
so after importing major libraries let's
move forward and start creating user
interface
so I will write here import sorry
root equals to
TK
put dot
title
simply learn
to speech
inverter
root Dot
geometry
I will give a thousand
Plus
200 from y-axis and
and
80 from Top
okay
root Dot decisible
will make it to like false
false
and again false
okay
then
dot configure
background should be PG equals to
use here hash
F7
AC
or zero
and
okay first I will explain this so here
TK stands for TK entered Library
every word in the string returned by the
title
method begins with an uppercase letter
like a title or a header the following
letter will be changed to uppercase if
the word contains a number or a symbol
one of the built-in methods in TK enter
is geometry
which is used to specify Dimension while
TK enter widget windows are mostly used
to set the application Windows Dimension
length
the TK enter root Windows size can be
changed in accordance with the needs of
the user using the resizable this one
or we can forbid resizing of the TK
enter window in other words this
approach can be used to generate a
window with a defined size
Simple Text changes can be made to
labels using python TK enter config
function
two widgets are shown in the example
below
a label and a button when the button is
pressed a function that is attached to
the button execute the label config
method
you can give background color as per
your choice I've gave this orange
something
so let's run this and see the first look
of UI by writing here I will write here
root
Dot main Loop
I will run and all
okay
so this is how our UI looks like first
UI so I can't resize because I gave here
false
I can't resize it
so if I will write here
instead of false I will write here true
and again
through here
so then I will run again
so now I can resize it
as per my choice
hey
yeah
so I will write here
false and again false
meant it
okay let's move forward and add some
logos in the application
I have already some PNG images on my
system you guys can use any picture of
your choice
I have some images here
images
so
you guys can use any picture of your
choice
so I will write here
simply
underscore logo
first two
photo
image
file
then part of file
e
zers
slash SLP
0 9
top
and
ETS folder
yes folder
then
simply dot PNG
okay then I will set label
put
H equals to
in play image
empty logo sorry
and background
I can copy from here
Dot
place
2.
880 and y axis should be
like I will give here of five
Thirty
okay
let's run this root
dot in Loop
okay there is something error
such file directory
a there is one
now let me run this
yeah now you can see simply learn is
there I need a little bit down
so let me write again
if here
run it again
okay now it's looking good
yeah
the image object is written by the photo
image function output it's that easy to
display a picture in Python however the
photo image class only supports the GIF
and PNG images
which is a concern JPEG and gpg and PNG
are the formats that are most often used
the container box where the text or
images can be placed is specified by the
label
the widget is used to inform the user or
other widgets that are utilized in the
python application
the text or a portion of the text shown
in the label can be configured using a
number of different parameters
the root window is where all the widgets
are placed
this one the road window is this all the
widgets are placed
even TK enter application must include
precisely one increase of the class TK
which is an instance of app is a
subclass of frame
and app is in instance of app
by positioning them in a precise
location with the parent widget report
manager organize visits the option used
by the geometry manager our anchor
border mode height width real with X and
Y anchor shows the location where the
widget is anchored
okay let's move forward and add the logo
here instead of this add One logo here
so I will make it comment down
it yeah
so for that I will write logo
underscore image
equals to
photo
image
then file
just do
we'll copy the path from here
okay so let me change it to speech
dot PNG perfect so root
dot icon photo
false
for my logo
underscore image
put dot Main
let me run this
yeah now you can see a logo here
so the image object is written by the
photo image function
output it is the easy to display a
picture in Python however the photo
image class only supports the GIF and
PGM which is a concern JPEG gpg and PNG
are the formats that are most often used
the title bar icon of the TK enter top
level window is set using the icon photo
but in order to set an image as the
title bar icon it must be an object of
the photo image class
so okay logo is added
this logo is added now we will make one
upper frame like this one upper frame
till here something like here
and we will add the heading and logo in
the frame
okay
so let me do this let me make it as a
command
yeah so I will write here upper frame
was to frame
that drought
and background should be
you can use any color so I will write
here hashtag one four
a
seven DD
cool then width should be
yes I can give it 1200 is enough
and height should be
and 30 is fine
so upper
m dot place
is equals to
and
y equals to zero X and Y equals to 0 y
because we need at the top
so I will add one
picture there so picture
pursue
again photo
image
I can copy from
yeah same image I will add then label
and when I'm where I'm adding here is
like upper
frame
image equals to
and background
should be the same
and Dot place
equals to
150.
and Y should be like I will give you a
20.
okay so let me run this dot dot main to
will run this run all
yeah
okay
okay here I have to write
y equals to 20.
and again
okay here what they should f is capital
hope now it will run properly
so the image is added here
yeah for the purpose of grouping and
arranging other widgets in a
user-friendly manner the frame widget is
a crucial it functions like a container
that organizes the positioning of other
widgets
to arrange the layout and provide these
widgets the screen uses rectangular
regions
the root window is where all the widgets
are placed even TK enter application
must include precisely one instance of
the class TK
and the label is specifies the container
box where the text images can be placed
this widgets used to inform the user or
the other widgets that are utilized in
the python application
the text or a portion of the text shown
in the label can be configured using
several different parameters
okay so logo is added and it's looking
great
so
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding
any sort of code
so just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
I'm repeating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
questions or any query regarding any
code or if there are any question
related to python just put as in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
moving forward let's add a heading to
the application
so I will make it as a comment
first I will add
[Music]
um
else below
better View
okay
so for that I will write here label
I have to head adding at the upper frame
so I will write here upper frame
could be
will give
X
each
converter
on should be
times
new
command
yes side should be 40 is enough I guess
and it should be bold
comma
PG background color should be
I will add this one only so copy
paste it here
and foreground should be
White
and Dot place
at x equals to 250
and Y should be the same I guess I
should be
I will write 35
to 30.
let's run this root
dot main Loop
okay
run this
okay it's like option front
okay this is font I
want sorry my bad
it will work
I guess
yeah
so here you can see
X is added
so for the purpose of grouping and
arranging other widgets in use of
finding manner the frame widget is
crucial it functions like a container
that organized positioning of the other
widgets
and the label is specify the container
box where the text or images can be
placed this widgets used to inform the
user of other widgets that are utilized
in the python application
and in PK enter there are three
different ways to specify a widget type
to put it simply use the string format
TK
direct phone format times 20 italic or
bold
font family size styles is the structure
of the string where style can be any
legal mashup of text style keywords
okay so heading is added now let's move
forward and make our text box for
writings text to it
so let me make first just as a comment
okay
so we are creating text box so I will
write here text box
equals to
text
and root window so I will write here
root
font
so let me tell you first I will create a
text box like this or this
so font
equals to
Library
and background should be black or white
okay let's do black first
let it take it white only white
and relief is something
relief equals to
Groove
and wrap
pivots into
word or characters word
word
and border which should be
zero
okay
so text
box
dot place
should I place it x equals to
30.
comma y equals to
comma width
should be I will make it the longer one
so I will write here
then height
should be
180.
so let's run this first root Dot
main Loop
let me run it
so yeah text box is created
hello guys
yeah
so textbook is created so the python
application uses the text widgets to
display text Data the single line text
box is implemented using the entry
widgets which TK enter offers the
multi-line style text is with a variety
of styles and characteristics is shown
using the text widget
instead of group you can use raised flat
Ridge and many more it is used to make
contact within a text document with
using the wrap features in TK enter we
may enclose the characters or words in
the TK widgets you can use word cares or
none are they available default values
for the wrap properties
the TK enter button BD option determines
the width or stroke of the Border that
encircles the button
the width of the Border round a button
can be changed using the BD
so by positioning them in a precise
location with the parameter
the put manager organized widgets the
option used by this geometry manager are
anchor border mode height width
X and Y and many more so our text box is
created
you can write anything
now let's move forward and add some
combo box for selecting voice and speed
so first I will but I will do it I will
make it comment
here
I will write
Tender Box
for male female
or equals to
combo
box
put
hello
is equal to
email
and font should be
should be
your phone should be r
o b o
t e and 12 shells should be 12.
then there is something called state
ah
and then
width
12.
and
gender box
or place
so I will press something here
something here like gender should be
here and speed should be here
so I will write here
is equals to
40.
comma
y equals to
400.
and gender box
dot set
to mail
run it so root dot Main
to
let me run this
yeah so you can see male female yeah
this is combo box
so a combo box combines an entry field
and a list box one of the Tinker widgets
it has down arrow to choose from a menu
of possibilities it aids consumers in
choosing from the list of available
option
a pop-up of scrolling list box it
displayed down the entry field when the
user clicks on the drop down arrow on
the enter field
only when an option from the list box is
selected with the selected option be
shown in the entry field
if I will select errors then it will
show female of male
so some variables supported by TK enter
can be used to change the values of TK
inter widgets these variable operates as
a typical variable would
the values of these variable are set and
retrieved using the set and get methods
combobox combines a list box widgets and
an entry widget you can choose one value
from a group of values using a combo box
widget you can also input a custom value
in addition
so set text is used to set the text in
the entry box in the python TK enter it
serves the purpose of your entering text
into the entry box when used as a
function
we will write a function and use as a
button to invoke it
so okay so it's look great moving
forward let's add one more combo box for
the speed one like Fast medium and slow
so whatever I will do I will copy
first I will make it as a comment
so first I will copy this and I will
paste it here
and I will write
beatbox
again
hitbox
in
box
and I will set it to medium
and that there will be three values like
past
am
and
slow
and I will place combo box
where should I place
we'll place it something
like here I will place it here
so
for that
I have to give X as
round 540
and why should we say so
let me run this
and let's see
so yeah so it's looking fine function I
used here is same as the previous one
that we did for the gender one for this
one
so I hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding
any code any sort of code so just put as
in comments our team will shortly
provide you the current solution I'm
repeating again I hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
question or I can any query regarding
any code just put as in comments our
team will shortly provide you the
correct solution
so moving forward let's add play button
to playing the return tags but before
that let's add something called select
voice and select speed label for these
two combo works for like select select
voice type and select speed
so let's add them quickly so I will
write here label
I am adding it to the root windows so I
will write here root and text
equals to
select
voice type
and font
should be
times
woman
and size should be like 15 is enough I
guess it should be pulled
comma
background color should be I will
here
copy
paste
yeah
foreground color should be
White
dot place
equals to
E40
and Y equals to
p 70.
okay let me copy this for the speed
up it and I will paste it here
I will write here speed
everything same
cut it and I will paste it here for the
running
so let me run this
select speed is there I don't know where
you select okay
okay I gave the same X values I guess
yeah
so here I have to write 540
let me run this again
yeah select voice mail female select
speed fast medium so
the python application uses the text
widget to display the text Data the
single line text box is implemented
using the entry widget which TK enter
offers
a foreground color of a button is set
using the TK enter button FG parameter
alternately the text color is on the
button
so it is looking cool now moving forward
let's add play button
somewhere here
so
I will write code for it
a
button
to I have one photo for it
Auto
let me copy the path
it here
and
that light play
then play
scope vtn
was to button
text
equal to X should be a play
and there is something called compound
so left
image
pursue
a button
comma
background should be
White
and width
is 130
font
equals to
Ariel
t
old
um
border width
should be
2.1
e
c means centimeter
and there is something called command
equals to speak now
okay
it's cool
ptn Dot
place
X should be
by
should be
let me see don't
mean to
make it comment
okay okay
so this is a function
we haven't created function yet so I
will add it at the last
so till
see
is on a border with
okay okay w i d t h
I hope now it will work
a TK enter
or in my bed
it's
yeah
so a python application can add buttons
by using the button widget these button
can show text or images that explain
what they are for when a button is
clicked
you can connect a function on method
that is called automatically using that
command
so here compound determined the best way
to display text and an image or the
label cursor
find how the mouse will look when it
over the widget
so the TK enter button BD option control
the Border width or stroke surrounding
the button
and some TK inter widgets let you use
command binding to link a callback
function to an even
it enters that you may specify a
function name in the widgets command
option
so that it will be called whenever an
event occurs on the widget
okay so our UI for the text to speech
converter application is created and it
is looking fabulous
so now let's add function for converting
the text to speech sound
let me write the code first and then I
will explain you line-wise
okay
now we can write here
command equals to
Peak now
okay
so what I will do I will add a function
here
I will add function here
so let me write the code first then I
will explain you line wise lies
so here I will write
ETS TTS is nothing just text to speech
variable
e y t t sx3
dot init
EF for function speak now
next
equals to
X underscore box
dot get
1.0
LD and
gender equals to
Tender Box
okay dot get
and speed
equals to speed the score box
dot get
voices
equals to DTS dot get
property
voices
okay so there is one another function
set voice
if
gender
equals to equals to
male
ets.
s that property
it should be capital
property
[Music]
yeah
voice
ID voices ID should be
zero
dot ID
s dot say
whatever written on text
Dot
run
and
I'm done for then else
PTS
dot that
property
boys
voices
button
dot ID
s dot say
text
and again TTS Dot
done
and
oh
here's I will for
I will write code for that speed if
text
and again if
speed plus 2 equals to
past
and
ETS dot set
property
and rate
should be
at two voice
live
or else if
feed
also equals to
m
so then
ETS dot set
property
and rate should be
150.
that voice function will be called
else
EDS dots that
property
ets.set property and rate should be
H should be
60.
at voice
okay so function is created dot get dot
get get property fine text
now let me run this
yeah
so let me explain you
TTS is nothing just a variable
to text to speech and init pytics X3
engine has started obtains a pointer to
an instance of an engine that will
utilize the specified driver if another
engine instance is already using the
given driver the other engine instance
is returned if not a new engine is built
so speak now is a function which using
get function I am getting the values of
that text box voice
I will show you it
so
from this
from this speak now I am getting the
value of text male and female then speed
and using the get property I am getting
the voices of male and female
in set voice what I did using ID 0 for
mail and assetting into the mail and
using id1 for female and assigning it to
the female
and in this LC slider I am setting speed
to a particular values using the rate
function and assigning them speed in
frames per second
so now let's see text to speech
converter since working or not
so what I will write here hello
orders
welcome
to
simply learn
so I will play
hello coders welcome to simplerlearn
hope you hear the sound
I repeat hope you heard the sound
and same thing I will from to from
female
a object run and wait
okay there is an error
run and wait
I will write
let me run this again
hello simply learn
hello simple learn
and again with female voice
I will write here hello simply learners
subscribe
to our
YouTube
Channel
hello simple Learners subscribe to our
YouTube channel
then I will play it too fast
hello simple Learners subscribe to our
YouTube channel
and I will put slow
hello simple learners
subscribe to our YouTube channel
[Music]
and with that we have come to end of
this video on AIML projects full course
I hope you found it useful and
entertaining please ask any question
about the topics covered in this video
in the comment section below our experts
will assist you in addressing your
problem thank you for watching stay safe
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to no more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign